deux animateurs des personnes âgées et
des chouettes ce sont les ingrédients
nécessaires pour un rendez vous original
la chouette thérapie tous les mois les
pattes de gaz rend organise cette
activité pour ses résidents c'est une
activité qui est complètement insolite
puisque on n'a pas l'habitude de voir
des chouettes au des hiboux
régulièrement et mais on se rend compte
que des résidants qui pourrait être un
peu renfermé qui ne discutent pas
beaucoup et on voit leurs visages qui
s'illumine mise en place depuis 2010 9
grâce au mécénat de l'entreprise gecina
immobilier dix séances d'une heure
environ sont organisées par an à la
manoeuvre le parc animalier l'espace
rambouillet qui compte 150 rapaces le
fait d'apporter un animal sauvage dans
une résidence et de faire voler cet
oiseau se faire porter sur le dos ça ça
m'a en place des émotions des souvenirs
ça fait bouger les résidents aussi parce
qu'il faut se lever
tendre le bras rappeler la chouette ça
les moeurs hors valeurs lundi 12 avril
une vingtaine de résidents participer à
cette chouette thérapie un bon moyen
pour découvrir ou redécouvrir ces
animaux et en apprendre un peu plus sur
eux moi j'adore tous les animaux alors
je suis j'étais grand tante et j'ai
passé une bonne après enfin une bonne
journée agréable parce qu'on apprend des
choses toujours sa saisie mais on l'a on
a peur si vous voulez sans avoir peur
c'est absolument génial
il ya deux personnes qui sont vraiment
très cultivé qui nous aura appris
beaucoup de choses
une conférence sur les rapaces est
également organisée avec l'espace
rambouillet d'ici deux semaines dans
l'établissement des activités plutôt
chouette donc que les pattes de gaz rang
et ses 90 résidents espère faire
perdurer longtemps